uh glenn how are you doing
good drew it's great to talk to you
great to talk to you last time i talked
to you you were had a
short film on a phone so i feel like
we've come a long way
since then um i want to ask first you
know
and without you know sending you back to
therapy but you
developed uh rapunzel for a long time as
a director
and i was wondering what you took from
that experience and applied
when finally getting to make over the
moon everything that i
loved about directing rapunzel and then
it became tangled
i just took it to the next level on this
movie
um really wanting the subtlety of
performance
in fifa's space and designing
characters that we're going to deliver
the thing that i i love in our
characters is that
believing the impossible is possible
animating
in her eyes that kind of
crazy drive of this little 12 year old
girl is gonna build a rocket to the moon
she's so smart she knows math and
science and physics
and yet also has this belief
from her mom this faith to see what
others don't see
that that's the joy that i wanted to
be able to to do in this movie was there
ever
talk of it being a 2d hand-drawn feature
well i was certainly given that choice
um
the wonderful thing about netflix and
is that they really give enormous
creative freedom
to you um and
i knew that there was one part that i
for sure wanted to do
by hand and that was this scarf
animation
when i read that i was like okay that
has got to be
that's mine i'm going to do that myself
for it i researched ancient chinese
drawings and really learned
the rhythms of the flow of of
those the scarf the movements in china
as she would fly through the air
and put that into the animation
but the thing that really drove me to go
cg
with this um was
what i saw in wizard of oz uh
wizard of oz in a lot of ways is a
a great um
example for our film where they went
from this black and white
to technicolor that
fantasy world was so remarkable and i
was thinking how in the world
are we going to do that and i remember
seeing
the um pink floyd's dark side of the
moon
album cover with that prism and the
white light
exploding into a
rainbow of colors and light it was about
light
and that's what this was going to be on
earth it was going to be
reflected light in this little town of
china
on the moon in the dark side of the moon
in lunaria it was going to be
source light exploding out from
the inside out and that
that made all the difference in the
world when celine de ramon a production
designer showed me the first image of
a in front of lunaria
i all i could do was laugh and cry
at the same time it was so beautiful you
could only do that in cg i'm assuming
that kind of illumination
right you can only do that in cg yeah
um can you talk about working with with
john because he's not here today but i
would always love to
i would love to hear what that dynamic
was like i mean you guys are
are uh illustrators who have used
computer
animation and la and hand-drawn sort of
together in really interesting ways
um what was that partnership like
halfway through the film
i realized how wonderful it would be to
have a partner like john
uh as this film was moving at such a
lightning speed
um to have someone who thought in many
ways
like i do and yet bring something
fresh and new his there was
there was one point in the movie palin
chow
melissa cobb um they would make
suggestions here and there and
i always had a choice of whether we'd do
it or not um
but at this point
i finally realized they were right i
needed to add this little
moment into the film where fei-fei is
running with this gift and
loses it that was
she hadn't lost it yet and we were we
were hearing from palin
she's got to lose it one one more time
and uh i realized that but we only had
like
five minutes left
to actually lock the film right
and so i quickly was storyboarding and
sketching as fast as i could what i
thought
and then then there's john sitting next
to me and he's drawing it
and then we both finished at the same
time we realized we had the same idea
but
his was like a bird's eye view looking
down
planning where all the cameras would go
mine was
the images of the character moments and
what the acting would be
and it was such a great compliment uh
john
is left-handed i'm right-handed as we
would be working with
the animators in vancouver
he and i would be sitting shoulder to
shoulder and some poor animator had both
of us
drawing together at the same time over
top of
their work um it was
it was a really wonderful partnership
with him
well can you talk a little bit about
sort of wrangling these different
animation studios and you've got pearl
in china and what that sort of was like
uh especially as a first-time feature
director i
imagine that was uh a lot
jenny rim is an incredible producer who
builds a team around you that's kind of
the perfect team for you it fits
like tailor-made clothes you feel like
you're surrounded by the best
and we tested various studios before we
went with sony
and worked with sasha coming to bangka
that was
and working with him was incredible he
has such
a um um
a sense of who the animators would be
the best ones
for us we really were searching for
as many people who had an asian
background as possible
to bring that sensitivity to it uh jenny
and palin were both
asian um all of our voice talent were
the artists in shanghai that really
helped me
a lot about acting choices
in this movie although it was being done
in vancouver um
we traveled back and forth many times
but on my wall in my office was a big
monitor and that was my window to the
world because we were working with
people in holland and
shanghai and france and spain
and and i just got to to go to all those
places
and it was great training for when the
pandemic hit that right
moving forward well glenn thank you so
much for taking the time to chat with me
i love the movie and it's always a
thrill to get to talk to you so
enjoy the rest of your day and hopefully
we'll talk soon yes thank you drew it's
great to see you again